có đau thế giới, bình Việt tâm ai lập kí lục vượt móc 1 ca. thay khó phức tạp mằng siêu rebot AI.
Người bệnh thóc Mi Cơ tàn phay, Chí Ví chỉ từ 1 ca. mâm lâm siệu.
Có á sục bởi vì tế, háng sản xuất rebot 18 tây giờ của dây số vừa công bố chút mừng và đánh giá cao thình tích của bình Việt đã qua tâm ai sau khi bình Việt vượt móc 1 ca. thay khó phức tạp mằng rebot AI kí vết choa thế hệ mới.
Còn mất này được tích lập chỉ khoảng 1 tăng sau khi tâm ai lập 8 chiếc với bà chiếc nghiệm cút tế sức sắp về phố thuật thay khó bằng rebot kí vết choa thế hệ hệ.
Ông trời dòng dinh, giá đốc từng hại cút tế, háng rebot cuu dây số.
Đing giá tôi bộ đặt hơn 1 ca. mộ và tỷ lệ thình công 1 ca. vình ca. mình trong cộ bình Việt tâm ai cũng tốt đậu thế giới.
Bộ trội số với kí khoảng bán đầu được vi nhận tại các bình Việt lớn ở trâu au, hàn quốc, ở nộ, thông phương, tại nhiều cơ sởi tế cút tế,
phải mất sau đến mấy 2 tháng để đặt được có số 1 ca. vô thuật robot sau việc lựa trọn bệnh nhân.
Đào tạo như lực làm chù công nghệ và các kí thật linh quan, kể thuốc ưu tụ tình sĩ bác xí trời khoa hài liên bân tấn,
giá nóc chung tâm trên thư trình hình. Kể thống bệnh viện đã qua tâm ai in tình phố gì mình.
Chào biết phần lớn trong hôn 1 ca. thay khó bằng rebot, ai thì hệ mối được ưu tiên chỉ định cho những ca bệnh phút tạc.
Bộ rất khó khó khó tìm thực hiện tình công và an toàn ca bằng các kí thật trình thống hay các bố tế hệ của,
như người bệnh đối mạnh vi cơ tàn phế sau bình sạch khó tạc phó tự sức, có giúp phần mềm.
Vìm dính khóp, lệ trục chi, ló sức nặng, mắt nhiều bệnh điên họ có này phí xò gái xương cạnh theo.
Phó thuật bối rô bố tế hệ mối đã giúp đều sị thình công ngoại mong đợi, hết đau, khó phục khả năng đi lại.
Điện lạch hợp của ông Hàu, mấy mít tối, là người thử một trong thay khó khối bằng rebot, ai kiểu viên cho tại mình vệnh tâm anh.
Ông bị thой hóa khó khó của dạc đẩn của ý, đau đấn không thể đi lại.
Tình sĩ bác xí trời khóa hai liên văn tấn chỉ định thay khó khó bằng rebot, kiểu viên choi,
phần mềm, ai giúp lập kế hệ chức mục, định vị cắt xương và hỗ trợ đặt khó trình rất tình mềm.
Băng ngày sau mục, ông Hàu sức viện đi lại nhẹ nhàng.
Chúng mình mục kia thay khó bằng rebot, ai hoàn tệ chỉ khoảng 6% đến chiếm với phút với ghi vị trợ
ngoại khoảng 780 lắm trở lòng. Chỉ măng khoảng 11% với các nước sử dụng cùng lại rebot và được lượng nhiều hạn bục bà hiểm i tế theo quy địch.
Bánh nhân ít mất mẫu, giảm đau giữ quả, có thể tập phục hồi chức năng sớm và đều rất hay lòng với kế khoảng điều gì.
Khó viên tạo xấu mũ mạng lại cầm giá tự nhiên, người bệnh đi lại thời mái ít có cầm giá phục viểu.